[Musique]
martin de biron michel david sébastien
bovet bonsoir c'est pourquoi alors on a
ouvert l'émission avec cette nouvelle
quand même je le dis je le soulignais sa
première fois qu'un guy ouellette a été
arrêté je me suis moi là le choc dans la
salle des nouvelles
comment ça aurait été un député un
guet-apens
on lui avait fait on l'avait appelé
vingt simule un autre chose avec un
cellulaire emprunter quelle histoire
martin paul avait dit à l'époque à
l'assemblée nationale b qu'on s'excuse
ou ceux qu'on accuse ailleurs il s'était
servi de seul pour faire sont-ils
d'olive bref je vous fais entendent
aujourd'hui monsieur gaudreault le
nouveau commissaire - nouveau le
commissaire de l'upac qui s'excuse et
les réactions ensuite convient après des
faits ont démontré que l'arrestation de
monsieur ouellette par l'upac résultats
d'une enquête fautive à certains égards
et que cette arrestation était
injustifiée du pacs excuses des
conséquences dévastatrices que cette
arrestation et cette enquête intrusive
ont pu avoir sur des filles
professionnelle et personnelle du député
de chomedey celle de sa famille et de
ses proches ainsi que celle de ses
collègues parlementaires aujourd'hui sur
une importante étape
je vous dirais que vous connaissez mon
histoire ça fait quatre ans que ça 2 ce
matin jean kaïs le coup je vous
demanderai de respecter ma décision de
ne pas commenter la déclaration de du
pack de ce matin c'est robert lafrenière
l'ancien commissaire de l'upac et wallet
dans son livre 6 une trame de fond qui
montre dit il une vengeance entre lutte
entre la fronière et lui entre autres
une lutte de pouvoir martin biron est ce
que ça vous étonne aujourd'hui cet autre
coup d'éclat quoi c'est clair que guy
ouellette a gagné son pari puis c'était
pas évident qu'ils étaient pour le
gagner a toujours dit que j'avais rien
fait et qu'il était pour la vie sa
réputation est franchement quatre ans
plus tard ils réussissent parier là que
le commissaire de l'upac se déplace à
l'assemblée nationale on comprend que
c'était ses règles à lui dans l'entente
qu'il a conclue et qui s'excuse
clairement là on voit pas ça souvent et
c'est une saga
quand même importante et ça aurait pu
durer beaucoup plus longtemps que ça se
serait dit il manque quand même un
morceau au casse tête et vous en avez
fait et en disant que
robert lafrenière le monsieur ouellette
dans son livre disait qu'il faisait un
power trip et qui il faisait tout pour
mettre la politique à ses pieds
s'assurer qu'ils soient confirmés dans
son poste ou et robert lafrenière qu'est
ce qui se passe avec robert lafrenière
il est chez lui peu et qui était est en
fait l'impression qu'on a c'est qu'il
est peu inquiété mais quand même son
règne à l'upac a été particulièrement
catastrophique qui nous a habitués à des
coups d'éclat souvent raté le code de
guy ouellette en étant quand même
arrêter un député en fonction sport rien
rappelez-vous qu'il arrêtait il ya donné
feu vert l'arrestation de nathalie
normandeau le jour du budget aujourd'hui
ces accusations la deuxième fois la
route
il lui même démissionné le jour des
élections générales
il est chez lui il est l'objet d'une
enquête du bureau des enquêtes
indépendantes on présume qu'on se penche
sur ce qu'aulas mais il est quand même
peu inquiété sur ce qu'il a fait ou on
va revenir avec un buis après l' enquête
sur l' enquête sur l'anc est celle
d'avesnes sur la journée d'aujourd'hui
parce que martine a raison le soulier il
ya une entente on connaît pas tout les
tenants et aboutissants de l'entendre il
ya une entente et dans l'entente mais ça
venait avec des excuses j'espère
j'imagine qu'il doit y avoir un certain
de demain pour monsieur ouellette parce
qu'il y est clair que ça a eu des
conséquences désastreuses pour sa vie
politique est très certainement procès
vue personnel je m'étonne même que ça
ait pris 4 1
ça commence à avoir l'air de
l'acharnement là parce qu'à écouter la
s'il y avait eu quelque chose il me
semble qu'on aurait dû découvrir ça
avant quatre ans et ils polluent pas que
je pense que c'est un autre coup dur
mais peut-être le clou dans le cercueil
là on sait qu'un rapport qui demandait
une fusion des corps des corps policiers
à l'intérieur de laquelle l'upac
disparaîtrait et ikki martin de 10l
depuis de paix ce que depuis le début
l'upac s'est conduit en carbo et ça ça
n'a pas de bon sens à cette espèce de
tracteurs qu'on avait tendu à monsieur
aux lettres la saisie de son téléphone
ou mépris de l'immunité parlementaire
même si elle s'étendra au delà des
bureaux ou de l'enceinte du parlement
et je pense que dans l'opinion publique
l'upac ces personnes et compte la lutte
contre la corruption de mais on a de
plus en plus l'impression qu'ils avaient
comme comme monsieur ouellette le disais
à l'intérieur de sa des règlements de
compte qui avait rien à voir avec avec
l'intégrité ou l'intérêt public
on a l'impression que c'était un nid de
vipères sébastien que vraiment on ne
sait plus même qui est bon qui est
méchant si c'est tellement complexe et
la première manoeuvrait dans tout ça en
tout cas s'il y avait la preuve que
ouellette était responsable des fuites a
jamais existé publiquement qu'ils mm
privée mais parce qu'on leur ai montré
j'imagine donc on est allé quand même
loin tout ça est un peu et
compréhensible non on est allé à la
pêche on ne respectant pas les simples
code policiers c'est à dire de monter
une preuve avant d'arrêter quelqu'un
puis d'abord une cro bat si solide pour
penser qu'on pourra accuser ces
personnes là je prends très juste un peu
de perspectives la vie de l'upac a très
bien commencé dans le monde municipal
rappelez-vous du maire de laval
vaillancourt laisse quand même une
grosse prise des pilules sarkozy
coupable tout de suite parce qu'il y
avait tellement preuve le procès mais si
on fait un grand bon temps dans les
toilettes alors oui en effet donc il ya
eu des succès instantané à l'upac dans
les premières années c'est par la suite
que ça a dérapé quand on est tombé dans
les cas de nathalie normandeau dans les
guy ouellette aussi et on a en effet
l'impression que ce moment là
direction du pack était dans un espèce
d'état d'esprit où elle voulait faire
flèche de tout bois puis faire des coups
d'éclat et c'est des coups d'épée dans
l'eau finalement et c'est à miner la
crédibilité
l'idée aujourd'hui c'est dire que comme
pour un restaurant on a tourné la fiche
qu'on a dit nouvelle administration et
on pense que monsieur gaudreault à
nettoyer l'ardoisé
avez vous entendu parler de fuite de à
l'upac depuis un an deux ans en fait
depuis que la nouvelle administration et
là on a l'impression quand même qui le
remit l'upac sorcière élu l'autre étape
parce qu'ils me l'avait dit ici sur ce
plateau est ailleurs monsieur gaudreault
que mature et un jour il devra
publiquement dire que c'est terminé lé
enquête sur le financement du parti
libéral
d'ailleurs monsieur charest qui est en
bataille judiciaire avec eux tu n'as
qu'un qui ne se terminent pas martin ça
c'est pas fini non plus ouais ça c'est
pas fini et ça c'est le gros morceau si
monsieur gaudreault sort pour s'excuser
auprès de jean charest et de marc bibeau
et du parti libéral ça ça va être une
bombe atomique dans nos salles de
nouvelles parce que nettement
ça fait plus de huit ans que l'upac
enquête dans ce dossier là et si ce
dossier là que fait l'objet de fuites
qui a amené goual est la danse en scène
et pour revenir à ce que ce que mes
collègues disent c'est vrai on a
l'impression que l'upac cécilia u2 du
pack qui c'est à dire l'upac de monsieur
gaudreault qui s'efforce de faire le
ménage et le dernier bout l'un d'eux le
dernier coin la nettoyer c'est
effectivement l'enquète macherez et là
on est huit ans plus tard bon il y aura
peut-être pas d' excuses en cause ma
chérie puisque a pas eu d'arrestation de
monsieur charest mais il va avoir
est ce assez inusité c'est rare que ça
arrive que la police faisait c'est
terminé on clôt l'enquète et compte tenu
des personnages impliqués bien
évidemment que ça va faire
ça va faire du bruit mais il ya du
dommage quand même et jean charest
déposée en cour supérieure conclut pas
justement pour essayer d'avoir gagné
justice est à dire a expliqué moi
pourquoi est ce que cette enquête là et
toujours au dessus de ma tête
huit ans plus tard oui je chercherai que
nous avons une entrevue qui furieux
qu'un pape du pack évidemment le jean
charest batailleur qui était revenue en
disant un peu ce qu'on avait laissé
l'entendent avec wyeth qui m'accusent ou
kim s'excuser parce que là ça puis bon
ça on va une partie de pêche
ok la fronière oui on a de l'entente
dont vous avez raison un marketeur
aujourd'hui ça va pas été de ça un
monsieur charest serait peut-être chef
aujourd'hui du parti conservateur ça va
pas été de toute cette histoire
ouais en tout cas quand il regarde les
sondages où tout lui doit se dire où l
enfant peut-être que j'aurais mieux fait
maison
ça c'est de la politique fiction le
sergent guy hoquet première est de temps
rattrapé les chirurgies ou québec
ça a été vraiment le victimes
collatérales au départ qu'on voyait pas
qu'on a commencé à entendre avec raison
ces gens qui attendent des opérations et
dans certains cas on a vu une dame
encore cas tant pour les deux anges
c'est très douloureux a plu presque plus
rien faire on écoute
monsieur dubé et son plein de rattrapage
au moment où on est dans la pandémie où
on peut dire qu'on stabilise
on a stabilisé des opérations parce que
vous voyez de moins en moins de de
délestage on a eu le bénéfice de
travailler avec des cliniques privées
donc on peut dire 2021 sujet caractérise
c'est la stabilisation c'est à partir de
2022 convoquons commencé à voir vraiment
une diminution importante sur cette
encourageant et en 2023 ben ce sera le
retour aux niveaux d'avant la pandémie
sébastien je commence avec vous c'est
vraiment une course collectivement qu'on
doit qu'on doit accélérer le pas ce que
des gens qui souffrent oui monsieur dubé
à son plein ce biais qu'il tint le plan
théorique moi j'ai bien de voir dans la
pratique comment il va réussir à
rattraper le temps perdu par la pandémie
évidemment il pouvait pas contrôler sa
fille c'est sûr qu'il est il y allait y
avoir des victimes collatérales
mais l'histoire nous apprend qu'elle
raison de la santé quand on essaie
d'augmenter la vitesse passer en
deuxième troisième quatrième vitesse
c'est très difficile
moi ce qui il ya deux choses qui me
frappe c'est que avant même la pandémie
il y avait 125 mille personnes en
attente d'une chirurgie ça veut dire que
même quand ça allait bien entre
guillemets il y avait des gens qui
attendaient pour une chirurgie première
chose deuxième chose c'est la face
cachée du délestage c'est-à-dire que on
est capable de comptabiliser le nombre
de chirurgies reporter mais quel est le
nombre de rendez-vous qui n'ont pas été
pris par des gens qui n'ont pas pu être
pris par des gens pour une consultation
des gens qui pensent qu'ils sentent un
peu moins bien mais qui est dans ton
normal aurait consulté un médecin et ont
pas été capables de le faire à cause des
coûts vide et sa éventuellement ça va
devenir des gens malades aussi donc il
ya plusieurs aspects à ces histoires de
délestage et de la colle et des vidéos
oui on voit les images de cette dame
cattin pas une mais deux manches
michel davet dont on nous dit aussi
d'être patient avant 2023 au travail
complet oui c'est très long à écouter
comme boudeuse qui a dit y ait des gens
qui souffrent il ya déjà et j'imagine
qu'on sera jamais capable de
comptabiliser sommet dont la vie a
probablement été
non seulement menacée mais qu'ils ont
perdu à cause de ça
c'est dans trois ans deux ans je
comprends qu'on dit allez on a fait les
lier les interventions les publics
prioritaires mais il reste qu'il ya des
cancers qui ont dû se déclarer qu'
arrêter et curable à l'époque ils sont
plus maintenant
et caetera et mais c'est bien beau les
et ses bas c'est le dit avant la
pandémie il y en avait déjà beaucoup
ici on avait beaucoup c'est parce
qu'avant un problème structurel qui est
pas réglé c'est à dire que la pénurie de
personnel qui a fait en sorte qu'on
reporte est déjà des opérations parce
qu'on n'avait pas le personnel les
infirmières en particulier pour défaire
ses interventions là et ce problème là
il est encore là
tant qu'on réglera pas ça on peut faire
du rattrapage mais c'est l'élimination
de la liste qu'il faut viser la
possiblement faire de votre part c'est
intéressant parce que vous touchez à
l'autre point important martin inscrits
monsieur dubé a le goût ont le souffle
en vie parce que être capitaine du
réseau en temps de crise on est là on
n'a pas le choix mais là ils vendent
partout ils ont été assez solide
là c'est la partie encore plus difficile
c'est la tempête et pas assez mais il
faut réparer structurellement ce réseau
là pour que ça marche mieux et c'est pas
évident non c'est pas évident parce que
le gouvernement est dans une situation
où il ya une obligation de résultat
parce que la pandémie est le mis au jour
où elle a mis la lumière sur un paquet
de travers le dans le réseau de la santé
puis bon on parle de chirurgie mais les
sièges celle des ou s'ils sont à revoir
les problèmes de santé mentale
il ya beaucoup de problèmes et la
pandémie a fait qu'on a accusé beaucoup
de retard sur leurs auteurs qu'on avait
déjà alors le gouvernement une
obligation de résultat de replacer ce
réseau là et ça sera pas simple parce
qu'il n'ya pas libres ou s'il est dans
une situation de pénurie mais de visa il
va il va être obligé de faire avec la
seule
le seul point j'aurais un des points
positifs quand même de ce que nous a
présenté aujourd'hui le ministre dubé
c'est que il nous présente un plan et
nous dit je devrais être capable de
faire ceci à partir de telle date là il
nous dit aussi que cet été il veut
donner des vacances au personnel de la
santé qu'ils en ont besoin et il nous
donne certes un échéancier
c'est une rampe étable ce qui nous
permet de vérifier de savoir où on est
rendu qu'elle savait au moins on a eu
plein de matchs très bien un petit mot
on va écouter pablo rodriguez à 3 pour
ceux qui doutaient compris par une
campagne électorale à tahoua écouter et
pablo rodriguez
la réplique conservatrice comme beaucoup
le pourra devenir des pros chez toi sur
la corde thérapie conversion sur la
carboneutralité
sur la culture ça c'est des choses que
les conservateurs bloquent actuellement
que les canadiens veulent et qu'on doit
faire adopter le plus rapidement
possible alors je ne cesserai
obstruction et a parallèlement deux
autres partis de de travailler ensemble
pour conclure fournisseurs aux canadiens
si par malheur on n'est pas capable de
gouvernement n'est pas capable
d'atteindre ses objectifs de passer
certaines lois mais il s'en est lui le
simple responsable d'abord il y avait en
tout c'est lui le responsable
c'est lui qui est responsable de
l'agenda si pour le gouvernement cette
pièce législature si pour ce
gouvernement là ces projets de loi
étaient si importants il y avait juste à
les appeler au moment opportun
on plaide du côté libéral avec pablo
rodriguez que de l'obstruction on place
la table on place la trame narrative
michel david pour dire on est bloqué il
faut aller vers le peuple
oui mais c'est évident que dans 1
dans un grand moment minoritaire
l'opposition a beaucoup de gros bout du
bâton alors monsieur deltell peut bien
avoir pu organiser ces fuites autrement
il reste que le gouvernement est
minoritaire
ceci étant dit je pense le gouvernement
pas besoin de prétexte pour déclencher
l'élection d'hier on n'est plus capable
de gouverner
écoutez ça fait ça va faire deux ans
l'automne que ce gouvernement est en
place tout le monde sait que c'est pas
mal la chute pour un gouvernement
minoritaire
y a pas besoin de vous nous minimiser ce
qu'ils disent oui mais ça lui prend
quand même un prétexte à lui prend il
faut qu'ils prouvent un certain blocage
même pas faire mais je pense que même
pas à faire ça à la limite tout le monde
satin et peut-être souhaité qu'il ya des
élections pour que la situation soit
clarifiée
sébastien quand vous allez recevoir vu
deux personnes sur votre passion en fin
de semaine pour souper parce que vous
avez le droit de faire le genevois
oui vous avez droit de faire une
personne vous incluant je suis pas sûr
que ça va susciter beaucoup de
conversation c'est à dire on est
beaucoup dans la bulle parlementaire moi
j'ai l'impression qu'ils cherchent un
prétexte quand même de dire que le
parlement ne fonctionne plus il a besoin
d'avoir les deux mains sur le volant
monsieur trudeau pour relancer
l'économie du pays
mais ça on est vraiment mieux
l'expression en anglais qui dit du
inside baseball on est vraiment dans la
bulle parlementaire je suis pas sûr que
cela excite beaucoup de joie à
l'extérieur depuis c'est oublier
s'oublier martin après une ou deux
journées de campagne
mais cette bonne guerre de mètres de
remplir son panier d'arguments si
j'annonce me poser des questions
ressortir la carte l'as de carreau
le roi de coeur
et si expliqué documenté finalement la
raison pour laquelle on dit quand des
élections
ils ont nouvelle carte au nouveau
brunswick à fredericton djenné cas at
one députés verts du parti vert qui s'en
va du côté des libéraux
ça c'est pas une bonne nouvelle pour la
chef du parti vert qui perd sept députés
alors vraiment en place la table pour
cette campagne
merci à vous trois à très bientôt